wenn ich mir diesen tag heute anschaue
dann bin ich schockiert habe aber
gleichzeitig hoffnung ich möchte damit
beginnen was mich heute schockiert hat
und was mich zutiefst traurig macht
erneut sind journalisten kollegen von
mir ums leben gekommen darunter ein mann
den ich gut kannte wie er sein name graf
kameramann für fox news wir sind uns in
afghanistan begegnet wir sind uns hier
in der ukraine eigentlich jeden morgen
begegnet denn an dem ort an dem ich bin
da war er auch er bis er vor einem tag
von einer moerser von mörserbeschuss
getötet wurde neben ihm eine ukrainische
kollegin alexander ebenfalls getötet die
angriffe auf journalisten nehmen massiv
zu bereits drei getötete journalisten
und mehrere verletzte das zeigt erneut
wie wenig rücksicht klar die mir putin
auf irgend ein menschliches leben auch
irgend ein ziviles leben nimmt auch
mehrere hochhäuser wohnblöcke wurden
heute morgen wieder attackiert das was
mir hoffnung macht und sehr viel respekt
abverlangt das sind die drei
regierungschefs die heute nach kiew
gereist sind unter anderem der polnische
ministerpräsident morawski und seine
kollegen was sie machen das hätte
eigentlich auch olaf scholz längst tun
müssen emanuel makro längst tun müssen
hier nach kiel fahren und wirklich die
solidarität ausdrücken zu zeigen dass
man bei den menschen ist und nicht nur
in brüssel oder berlin sagen dass man
bei den ukrainern steht nein diese
aktion mit einem zug ihr einzureisen in
einer höchst gefährlichen situation das
verlangt mir wahnsinnig viel respekt ab
und das gibt mir hoffnung dass es
hoffnung für die ukraine gibt
alles ist sehr bewegendes war gerade
auch bewegende stille selbst
wahrscheinlich im studio es tut mir
unfassbar leitbild journalistenkollegen
die du gerade genannt hast für die
familien und wir denken auch hier an sie
in berlin ich würde jetzt übergang kann
gar nicht gut gewählt werden in dem
zusammenhang danke dass du ihn gedenkt
hast und ich würde jetzt einmal zuhören
bosbachs schalten und in die frage
stellen sollte herr scholz nach kiew
reisen herr bosbach sollte unser
bundeskanzler sich jetzt auf den weg
nach kiew begeben um ein zeichen zu
setzen
paulus heimat gerade den richtigen
begriff genannt es ist ein zeichen es
ist ein symbol aber das sollte man auch
nicht zu gering schätzen es ist ja das
zeichen der solidarität und es ist schon
ein unterschied ob man das aus der ferne
bekundet die solidarität zu einem land
zu einem geschundenen volk oder ob man
selbst vor ort gemeinsam mit anderen
kollegen
mit der regierung in kiew spricht das
nicht nur ein zeichen der solidarität
ist auch ein zeichen des persönlichen
mutes aber ich maße mir nicht an aus der
ferne den bundeskanzler zu empfehlen
nach kiew zu reisen ich glaube es wäre
auch nicht klug wenn er ganz allein
fahren würde weil dann möglicherweise
sich jeder andere rechtfertigen muss
warum er dennoch nicht da hingefahren
ist wenn es der gemeinsame wille von
mehreren regierungschefs ist oder wäre
dann wäre olaf scholz gut beraten sich
diesem kreis anzuschließen aber ich
möchte von hier aus das ist in meinen
augen etwas überheblich olaf scholz
nicht sagen dass er nach kiew zu reißen
hat also ich bin da auch etwas
zwiegespalten ich finde es eine
wunderbare geste die im übrigen auch
unterstreicht wie nahe sich die
osteuropäischen länder sind was ja in
westeuropa oft vergessen wird die
geschichten der anrainerländer der
ukraine sind aufs tiefste verflochten
das habsburgerreich reichte natürlich
wissen nach lemberg und cherno witz und
litauen reichte weite teile bis zur
ukraine und polen war ein teil litauens
und der ukraine die geschichten sind
verflochten die menschen sind
verflochten was wir gerne übersehen ist
dass diese länder alle eigentlich schon
in sich vielvölker staaten sind und wir
haben dann immer so ein bisschen die
herablassende kommentierung gehabt wenn
sie sich geweigert haben in brüssel
irgendwelche quoten zu akzeptieren dass
andere was mich etwas zwiespältig auf
den besuch gucken lässt wenn das zur
regel wird das staatsmänner der des
höchsten formates gewissermaßen
menschliche schutzschilder abgeben geben
wir putin ziele in die hand die auf
einen schlag regierungen kopflos machen
könnten und ob ich ihm das gerne da bin
ich doch sehr im zweifel
für sie seien sehr gefährlicher besuch
da stimme ich dir absolut zu
und vielleicht paul auch an dieser
stelle
du warst in vielen krisengebieten du
bist ein kriegsreporter der
egal ob man vor sechs sieben jahren war
und da die ganzen unruhen miterlebt hat
auch die kriegerischen
auseinandersetzungen die es da in
anderer form aber auch schon natürlich
mit gefahr gab du warst in afghanistan
hat der gefahr der taliban in die augen
blickte war es in ägypten und wir haben
früher auch viel gesprochen in dieser
zeit ich glaube jeder jeder
kriegsreporter nimmt ganz ganz besondere
risiken auf sich gerade auch in dieser
zeit sind wir wieder mit tödlichen
gefahren die er sich aussetzt um sein
publikum den menschen der öffentlichkeit
eben darzulegen darzustellen
was vor ort passiert ich hoffe
dass das das leid der familien
irgendeiner weise
ertragbar ist es ja nie gemindert werden
kann es auch nicht sein aber dass du
auch vorsichtig bist und walten lässt
und in dieser phase auch nicht nur an
die großartigen geschichten für die user
und für die tanne leserinnen und leser
denkt sondern auch ein bisschen an dich
selbst denn wenn man so auf dem
erfolgreich auch berichtet hat und dem
hagel gestanden hat dann ist die gefahr
groß dass man die gefahr manchmal nicht
so einschätzt wie sieht dann eben
täglich für dich ist und deswegen alles
alles gute und ich und natürlich auch
den familien die davon betroffen sind
zudem besuchen das ist natürlich ein
starkes signal der drei und die klappe
es ist der tschechische
ministerpräsident vieler der gesagt hat
wir kommen hier nicht einfach so daher
mit leeren händen sondern wir bringen
ein großes paket der eu mit ich konnte
noch nicht nachlesen ob jetzt berichtet
worden ist oder bekannt geworden ist was
dieses paket nun beinhaltet aber
natürlich setzen und da bin ich bei ralf
auch die sich gefahren aus die wenig zu
kontrollieren sind
ob scholz dahin gefahren wäre besser ich
weiß nicht ob er dann sinn gehabt hätte
aber man kann sicherlich
eu-ratspräsident amtierender da wäre es
natürlich schön ein paar initiativen
mehr zu sehen als nur telefonate die
kein ergebnis haben aber wir werden
sehen was dieser besuch bringt und
welche ergebnisse er ja nach sich zieht
parade wolltest gerade schon einsteigen
wenn ich es richtig gespürt habe hinter
mehr
nein aber ich bin ich verstehe schon die
argumentation was natürlich die gefahr
mit sich bringt auch für regierungschefs
vorbei mein gefühl wäre dass wladimir
putin
doch davor
bleiben putin weiß man nicht aber dass
er doch davor einen regierungschef hier
zu töten zurückschrecken würde es gab ja
noch eine weitere initiative die in dem
zusammenhang interessant ist vitali
klitschko der kiewer bürgermeister hatte
gefordert dass der papst und weitere
religiöse anführer nachkommen sollten
dem papst liegt dieser brief vor auch
das fand ich eine spannende initiative
lenkt jetzt ein bisschen ab von der
frage ob die eu genug macht ich finde
dass man in deutschland langsam sieht
dass deutschland sich erneut sperrt also
was ich höre aus brüssel ist das erneute
wut darüber gibt dass deutschland sich
so zurückhaltend verhält zu weiteren
sanktionen dass man sich weiter wehrt
auch gegen bestimmte sanktionslisten
gegen bestimmte namen und das ist doch
was hier in der ukraine für schweres
unverständnis sorgt
ja das ist eine schwierige debatte auch
auf der europäischen ebene wird ja über
härtere sanktionen
gestritten und wir sind jetzt in der
position wo die abhängigkeit die merkel
immer wieder vorgeworfen ist und warum
warum so kritisch nachfragen gab bei den
nord stream zwei verhandlungen und bei
ihrer politik wo diese abhängigkeit sich
tatsächlich in schmerzhafte einschnitte
ummünzt und das ist natürlich ein
problem
was man so ein patient der dem arzt
schaden will indem man seinen tropf
rauszieht
ist zweifellos mutig aber
möglicherweise am ende auch krank oder
tod und diese debatte ist nicht einfach
zu führen das sind tatsächlich die
folgen einer massiven abhängigkeit der
lebensader einer industrienationen
nämlich bei der energie ich erinnere
mich einen abend der cdu parteitagen wo
mir der amtierende damalige
wirtschaftsminister ganz klar am rande
der veranstaltung gesagt hat vergesst
diese autarkie diese souveränität
brauchen wir nicht im neuen jahrhundert
beziehen wir energie jeder von jedem und
das ist alles von gestern das sind die
gefährlichen illusionen für die wir
jetzt bezahlen und für die vor allem die
ukraine bezahlt das ist extrem bitter
ich tue mich nur mit einfachen lösungen
da immer schwer wenn wir nicht aufpassen
droht putin den gashahn zu und sagten
mal werden wir wollen mal gucken ob ich
länger ohne euer geld leben kann oder
länger ohne mein gas ich weiß nicht wie
das ausgeht dass bach hier die frage an
sie bevor sie zu ihrem thema kommen war
die energiewende falsch von der union
also wir fangen noch mal eben vorne an
ich bitte an ronzheimer um verständnis
für meine zurückhaltung denn paul
ronzheimer selber geht hohes
persönliches risiko ein ich sitze hier
in ergolding bei münchen im warmen ich
setze mich überhaupt keinem risiko aus
und sodann anderen empfehlen nach ihr zu
reisen damit tue ich mich schwer zum
thema weitere sanktionen ich möchte
einmal gerne wissen ob die sanktionen
die schon beschlossen worden sind
tatsächlich bei uns in deutschland alle
exekutiert worden sind wir sperrt
eigentlich die konnten was habe ich
davon wenn in brüssel oder bei
eu-gipfeln wo auch immer
kontensperrungen beschlossen werden wenn
die flugzeuge der oligarchischen am
boden bleiben sollen wenn vermögenswerte
beschlagnahmt werden sonne oder gesperrt
werden sollen wenn gar nicht klar ist
wer eigentlich dafür zuständig ist diese
beschlüsse auch durchzusetzen wir
sollten erstmal mit der exekution
bereits getroffene beschlüsse anfangen
wer ist eigentlich zuständig der bund
die länder erwartet man darauf dass die
banken das von sich aus machen das würde
ich alles mal gerne wissen ob das schon
eins zu eins durchgesetzt worden ist und
bei neuen sanktionen ich möchte ich
gerne wissen wie es danach weitergeht
woher beziehen wir öl oder gas in
welchen mengen sind die liefermengen
gesichert und zu welchen preisen und
welche auswirkungen hat das ich glaube
viele sind bereit auch schmerzliche
einschnitte hinzunehmen wir dass das
leid der menschen in der ukraine lindert
aber es gibt auch viele die fragen wie
geht es denn danach weiter die
energiewende
wir hatten ja auch mal unsere regierung
angela merkel zunächst eine
laufzeitverlängerung des atomausstieges
der beschlossen worden ist unter der
regierung gerhard schröder dann kam das
unglück in fukushima dann kam der
ausstieg bis ende 2022 drei
reaktoren sind noch am netz und dann kam
das thema co2 vermeidung geht sind wir
dabei aus der kohleverstromung
auszusteigen
es gehen wir noch mal zurück auf die
debatte nach fukushima ich bin sehr
sicher hätten wir damals die debatten
lage von heute gehabt dann hätten wir
eher den ausstieg aus der
kohleverstromung
beschlossen wegen co2 reduktion als der
ausstieg aus der
atomenergie man darf sich das nicht so
vorstellen dass man die reaktoren die
drei die jetzt noch in betrieb sind ein-
und ausschalten kann wie er das licht im
büro das kann man nicht als ein höchst
komplexer vorgang technisch und
rechtlich
ich mache ohnehin an die energiewende
ein fragezeichen das führt aber jetzt zu
weit weil es um die grundlastfähigkeit
geht wir haben weder permanent wind noch
haben wir permanent sonne und wir
brauchen eine sichere und saubere
energieversorgung unabhängig von
witterungseinflüssen wir werden
weiterhin strom sowohl aus
kernkraftwerke als auch aus
kohlekraftwerken importieren müssen ton
aber so als wäre das nicht der fall und
das ist das problem was ich sehe und ich
sage ihnen drei vier jahren werden wir
eine ganz andere debatte haben als heute